round two beginning ring countdown yeah
I'm inside the next ring
Oh what's up everybody Persia and Max
here and obviously we are here to play
some eight pecks legends see yes the
solos the iron crown collection event
begins today and fun fact max was gonna
start up a game just to test it all out
but he's actually doing really well and
he's still in the middle of the match to
dive we're already starting so might as
well just stick to it and start in the
middle exactly I was like let's just
start this up real quick you're in the
middle of magic doing pretty good but
yeah you guys today is the very first
day the update is live we actually just
downloaded it and this is the first
run-through for max in solos mode so far
so good he has three kills actually
going really well
starting to totally kick start at the
stream and quick fashion but I didn't
want to die as we were waiting we heard
someone else's footsteps around us and
then we were really like alright get
into it get into it yeah it was like
Samia spicy so Liz's is interesting so
far you don't get any chances that like
assault survivor or anything like that
if you die you can bring this down just
a tad because yeah how much are the skin
charge is probably a lot okay you know
you save up that currency that in-game
currency to buy it but I feel like once
I saved it up for like one good skin it
took me forever to stack up again but ya
know sunny one says why is this game so
sweaty it really is it really is but
that's that's what's great but yeah
welcome everyone to the stream thanks
for tuning in and checking out solos
mode with us maybe after this we'll take
a look at the new skins they should be
up for preview and you should be able to
preview them so no focus there's only
six players left
we started the stream few minutes early
so we could capture the rest of this on
string I'm definitely a fan of this cuz
I'm always always in a 1v3 situation
with my team always dead and it's always
a full team against just me so adding
another layer so you know just focusing
on the battle you gotta go revive its oh
thanks
[Applause]
nice haul - where is Eric say Eric say
is busy men's or in this establishment
what's up mr. crew so you're awesome -
for two minutes thanks for joining us
today yes Raja sorry I totally [ __ ]
screaming but yes we do actually read
the comments here I'm excited for these
new skins right these are all like Game
of Thrones theme very yeah it's Walt a
gladiator Oh
gladiator okay okay I saw like their
Twitter promo where they were like you
know redacted first of her name and the
first thing I thought was just Dan F
alternator is so damn good you're right
especially with these disrupter rounds
now even after their nerf it's crazy
what up crying welcome back oh you know
what we all miss Eric I even miss
streaming with Eric he saw the entrance
and he couldn't help it
like I have to go
gamer his blog on that said get me a
headshot I mean there was one in there I
saw one gold damage yeah for a second
thing which means that's head shot are
critical or something like that what
about the self revive shields
never thought about that 30 second up is
probably in the air is still alright I
mean how we well actually we haven't
come across any knockdown shields yet
have we actually you know what you're
running there's no knockdown shields so
maybe not so maybe not chrome says I
need hangover strats what happened what
happened crime us now we hear gunfire
chase chase him only two players left
access is the last person oh I wonder if
that's two including you like it is in
the regular this is it let's go max yes
phase Paul solos is out we are playing
them right now let's go mercs oh she
don't know this is a test run and it was
iw it's after that let's go
I almost wish we started it like early
but it was supposed to be the test run
before we started history of VMs it's
all good we got the W on the stream it's
like so seven kills you do start with
the full sixty what's something else we
noticed like right when you drop the
ring is already there like you already
know where the first ring is which is
really weird cuz I never even noticed
that until you yeah and it's a long
first round it's like it's like three or
so minutes or is that it the same amount
as like a regular round I thought they
were a little short they were a little
shorter I feel like the match won by
really quick because that was like yeah
that was pretty good fifteen minutes man
yeah yeah yeah oh snap Bob Jones is back
it is going great we just got the first
W on the stream the home
collection it now oh yeah let's check
out those skins too before we hop into
another match yeah you know the chat
give me some props max hell to god ma
says GG thank you think gamers blog
honest is very nice
when did the update come out it came out
they said like 10 a.m. Pacific time mine
actually was available to download like
around ten twenty five ish thoughts I'm
forty five for Xbox are like nearly got
it flora so it varies it varies
okay Pathfinder has like a wraith had
one of the really really good-looking
ones his was like all-white not previous
come on we want to see them interesting
well you can buy them right with the so
they have to be around here somewhere
cool okay there's a lot of cool stuff
now in the store what a tease we just
want to see if you guys know where it is
yeah help we're pulling on Xbox today I
know you guys always talk about how
we're ps4 lovers but max here is this is
my main account
I don't play booth lifetime damage dealt
1.7 million
oh snap crime said he's gonna stream
snape you oh I'm gonna get ya in the
game right since I checked the store is
that where we were just now I was just
there but I didn't see that well we'll
look again yeah after the next match
will go back oh snap Roger oxide were
the first to stream a pixel oh is that
so well you've seen a here first on
GameSpot youtube.com slash can spot a
new spot yeah exactly
ooh max makin history out here in these
streets
but yeah
Oh Bob Jones is usually on PCs yeah I
guess PC is definitely the quote-unquote
mastery yeah also you can get some call
me a cheater because I have a elite
control is that the stuffer is that's
the Xbox version Xbox oh nice nice name
I actually like their paddles elite
version it's so nice it's crouching and
jumping yeah baseball says duos I know
people really want to drop to the new
area yeah it totally sticks out like a
sorceress I was reading something
oh it's duos out yeah that's something
super popular everyone once right now
it's duo to be great - it's a team-based
game I don't know why this nothing right
there like in the middle right they
don't have like a 4 player which is like
also pretty common than like you know
shooters common right 4v fours but then
they have the three years
I mean threes alright new mode I mean
new area oh it's like oh cool there's a
bunch of jump pad oh yeah wait I'm sorry
I'm just kicking all over the place
right now
the back story the back story they
posted oh dude we don't have a gun
if it wasn't for that first shot on your
way up you would have you know God like
passed by me or something that's weird
I think he jumped down he thought you
jump down and then you came back up and
you just JC back up oh go to shop events
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah your next game um
anywho I was saying did you guys see
they drop some like cool backstory stuff
of octene it was like chat log between
octane and lifeline where they kind of
talked about how octane lost his legs
yeah like he watches a bunch of like
YouTube stunt artists but they're all
like Holograms or something apparently
but he was like I'm gonna go do that and
then he tried to do it and tried to like
launch himself using a grenade and so he
blew legs off and then they started
talking more in the text chat and then
he eventually mentions okay what about a
jump pad instead of a grenade but then
lifeline ended up blocking him so yeah
it's really funny like it's adorable
it's awesome I definitely want to see
more of his backstory stuff from all the
e-text characters but but yeah I need a
story
it's good it's good it's like simple but
good octane Marian I just really liked
about back sorry it's cute and it makes
this area make more sense because this
looks like a stunt course or like a race
track of some sort it has all the jump
pads so cool
Oh purple run let's get out of it we got
our blue one attachments when the OL
Mike everyone wants to go the new area
alright yeah I need to get some weapons
first I'll come back yeah we'll go back
house I keep being really bad oranjee
and no weapons no problem
dull John's like he killed me with that
come on chica yeah he makes all of these
like really funny you know clips cuz is
he Mexican I'm not sure he's Mexican
okay cuz he's he calls her like her mama
and like and the classic which is
something I always just laugh at in
general I was like you know I you type
like ha ha ha yeah but like people who
see Santa I loved it so my name is so
funny
all right we're going back into the area
now we're prepared they play chess oh my
gosh here is that one flip where there's
just nothing but like toxic and Watson
traps
[Music]
and all you hear from the race
he's like chef sir so I got over and
over and over again like oh my gosh mr.
crew so that's Pathfinder who's ready to
fly on the zipline everyone in solos
nothing I like that one
all right we're getting sweaty for this
yes it is time
man there's still so much action over
here and look the ring isn't even over
here that's close oh oh I think they're
in the building you're on top oh my god
you don't know what to do you don't know
what to do you're not safe there you're
like I don't care I'm looting get that
backpack brother it's fine you're the
best so for that top tier joke I like it
oh this guy over there okay
when you got gold I'll to run your
pockets
look at that those numbers men giving
people the license back
how many victories you have to have to
get the skins for the event asks
explosive Phoenix yeah I'm not sure
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you enough Emmy says well done you
guys guys are doing amazing work we
appreciate that we do it all for you
guys which by the way Max and I have
released an awesome interview a with the
Street Fighter 5 evolution champion bond
Shawn if you are Street Fighter fan you
should check it out it's pretty great
it's interesting wait what none of these
zip lines were originally here before
right or someone placed that somewhere
because I was like oh god you guys I was
like maybe they added more to help
people you know get around
oh yeah and Max's habit of constantly
pinging even though there's no one on
the team all those shields are gone
where you rush them down not this time I
got to pick my fights like oh snap if
Emmy says that they're new to this game
but they're gonna start playing because
of us oh yeah well some tips you're
gonna die a lot yeah but once you'd you
know just get past that and learn as you
go it's all good but the cool thing is
now compared to like when I first
started there's like a training mode of
version now where you can kind of run
through without playing against a bunch
of people oh wait really yeah um so yeah
maybe try that a couple of times but it
is an intense sweaty game so size of the
update it was like 2.3 something or like
two and a half gigs or mine was for ps4
anyway I think he's like four gigs for
Xbox oh yeah I'll just double check it
again but didn't take too long to update
just like five six minutes I mean it
depends on your email oh yeah
mine took a long time actually and we're
on the same Internet alright 21 players
left 21 legends on a solo mission
because that you know what 2.6 gig
update says Harry Taylor 3.5 for the
Xbox one says Reese Morris so it varies
depending on your console re let's check
this event story real quick no no no you
must you must win this now alright was
gonna tell me do I quit out and go to
the store or stay in this game this game
will start way before the buffering
catches up to what the stream man I'm so
used to just going to the next game just
I mean that rotation man crane says Xbox
always has a bigger update noted noted
[Music]
damn it oh yeah that's a good update
crew so when Pathfinder says he's ready
to fly on a zipline we are he's talking
to us through the fourth wall
all right everyone said go we're doing
it for you see some people said hold it
see I'm on board I'm on board with Roger
win but it's okay it's done we need to
see these uh we need to see these skin
yeah where the hell are they fly to the
OSH I think it worse than both options
because it takes forever I wish they
would put some blue on top of the of the
way those things called in the middle of
the map now the big tall guys Bill of
Ivins
oh yeah yeah I put some loot on their
bags and let us land on that's what I
really want it make it like really a
small amount of loot and then make it
landable so it's just a fist fight on
top of the Leviathan but like good stuff
like all gold stuff but only enough like
one person want to go there cuz then you
know you don't want to promote camping
on top of the Leviathan kind of an
office - all right so events tour
wait we were there already I think even
shop ooh I like that one
actually that's like a Chinese here it
doesn't matter how cool you try to make
Mirage look he just always
but it's cream.i Pastis TV that looks it
does look good I want that one okay nice
yeah crypto isn't out guys he's all the
mentees it's gonna be a while till it
comes out it looks so good
Oh bloodhounds yeah yeah that looks so
good and I was like the one you saw in
the trailer that is cool
I like it I like it very shiny the
headpiece reminds me of BC like the blue
mitral blue ball Mike's oh yeah the ones
that like have a stick yeah that's a
little round circle yeah I have my
hitbox which really small yeah he's
right in your he looks thinner in this
one I know I smell Oh penis all right
caustic it's pretty cool yeah that one's
nice too
it's like a semi chainmail or something
matches Bangalore's
so far I like Danglars the best even
though I don't play it online race so I
love this like so sick yeah I like it
too cuz she's like she looks like she
just finished her first war and now she
was going to the next one veteran
exactly seasoned veteran she's got those
war pansies I know you have to collect
how do you collect these I would there
must be three packs I see I see I like
that one oh my god that what is so safe
will lead the mask from that Jim Carrey
movie probably the mask I think this is
the best one this is actually the first
time I've seen this alone it's like song
British - it's cool with the hair that
is so dope that is so cool and like the
offset armor so
and that's so cool that looks real okay
that's my favorite last oh yeah that's
my favorite one I think of the whole
[Laughter]
pac-man I never notice the tattoos
before yeah cool
yeah all the Similan vibes oh my God my
wings in the back - okay the wings are
kind of dope okay I like that
yeah I think lifeline has to be the
winner there yeah I think a lifeline and
Bangalore a second for me personally
even though it's like not anything
different for my normal skin it's just
super clean colors yeah and I like the
effects too um everyone is talking about
the heirloom set oh it's right was there
more than justice there's this you can't
really preview it yeah solo all right
well there's the skins you guys those
are pretty dope skins Eric Tay in the
chat oh he said he got a 10 kill champ
game it's okay I'm recording on this
side oh wait videos oh no working oh I
didn't record it no you know what it
doesn't matter because when that game
was going I was like afk for like oh
yeah even though it is still alright so
now max your goal is not only to win but
to get more than ten kilos you have the
Eric Eric score here seven kills yeah
you got seven kills on your first very
first game hey but it was the first solo
champion Austria yes
boom GameSpot let's go
yeah no octane skin
even will they give him a new area or
did we miss it we'll go back in like oh
yeah see a few people are saying he
doesn't have homes for you Eric says Rob
witnessed it and Eric is shaking the
adrenaline the pure adrenaline only
brought to you by solos mode here in
Apex dang record that Eric you got in
ps4 play or something
whoo Eric said there are self revives we
haven't run into one yet but that is
noise Mac Scott he played one game at
the very start and he won that one seven
kills yeah we started the stream half
way through because I had a feeling it
was gonna be a good one yeah let's
redirect I'll be back to collect the
bodies right start old oh snap
they've laid traps
Eric said oh it's recorded it's going up
good
I want to see it because that sounds
Hoyt and you said you saw a bunch of
solder right so that sounds even more
true evasion tactics exactly I wanna
come back to you know a battle Royales
are all about good decision-making
I guess the beginnings a better time
than ever yeah you wanted to chase me
buddy get some oh my god max you just
pick up that hon says you have to pay
real money for the skin technically no
but if you can probably get them a whole
lot easier if you do Oh Eric said he
killed someone with self revive and he
had one of his own so is it a knockdown
shield or is it just like a whole new
item that's just specifically a solver
buy it only because we haven't run into
it yet that's the goods
I hear feet okay
they're in combat
good I'm inside the next ring wait do I
actually hear footsteps um we're
tripping I thought I thought I heard
them to you but neither yours but we
said that last time look at me a lot of
you thanks for tuning in Ghana we'll
catch you next time you have a good day
now I'm just remembering that octane
that we randomly stumbled upon just
sitting in the corner
yeah Oh Oh big capital letters no from
Eric oh no the requi SATA rest in peace
my recording no what happened to it oh
that is a heartbreaker sating so damn
that sucks someone's up here that I
heard him I know me whew almost I swear
I heard some some walking that wasn't
yours yeah they might have just been a
lot further down towards the ground
that's that's fine now it's okay Eric
that just means you got to do it again
looking for a backpack oh yeah it is a
shield like well maybe oh my gosh
Brandon asks are the games any slower
than ranked I feel like this is slower
this is slower for sure I feel like
people a lot more happy and there's not
as many fights yeah cuz you've been
actively running around and really only
ran into like one person at the
beginning yeah which he got bodied
that's that one skull up there in the
top still 24 players I think after the
round starts closing it gets a little
bit more hectic though yeah
Matt Williams says we want to see a win
here
no pressure max I heard the slide -
there's some they're creeping on you
yeah
oh they're deathly creeping right oh no
Eric says he's so sad I'm sad for you
because any game that gets your
adrenaline pumping like that and makes
your body shake it's like you you need
that on footage it's all good run it
back Eric we believe in you well there's
definitely somebody here but I can't see
how much it's like you Boulder about the
crouch up to each other at any moment I
reveal I'm doing it for a screen going
ham extra ham gave up the height
advantage
easy peasy give me that armory give me
all your goods run your pockets
give me that cash yeah as you can see
I'm not great on looting after all this
shoot 18 players left and brown sea is
finally beginning prepare the next ring
no Dan F says be aggressive yeah I'm
trying guys yeah I don't like playing
too passive either but also there's a
lot on the line when people say that
they want me to win so I gotta like
which in between depending on where I am
you already have a better one I know you
ripped it right off that guy's back I
told you it's all good
honestly like even when I play a lot of
games back to back to back sometimes I'm
like oh I already have this I'm like oh
wait that was last game oops
anything new in the store asks Ricardo
well yes there is a lot of goodies we
already showed off the costumes but
there's even weapon skins and you know
the heirlooms set also oh snap there's
hope for Eric's recording he said it
might still be there
I believe okay there's got to be a way
you know you always had a Google in
someone has a workaround for everything
I swear yeah and I kinda feel like ps4
is always recording anyways so there may
be something yeah it's like the second
the round size clothing gel John says
sweat glands slowly open actually you
know what rape is actually really good
because she has that passive yeah that
she can tell you when someone's looking
at you
I mean who have we seen so far we saw a
Gibraltar a caustic we've seen octene I
really seen any lifelines yeah any good
- I'm still those
I feel like at that point with lifeline
it's like octane our DS have self feels
passively so if you want her for healing
you just pick off team care package
that's just gonna consistently give you
away you're right Jeff Max is a God at
this game I don't know if you saw this
profile earlier but over you got a
little bit of crossfire from the back of
pasta so that worked out but they're
happening get out of there oh no that
was unfortunate so third parties are
real in this game oh nice Eric said he
saved his gameplay clip boys can't wait
to watch it
and he also asks are you playing in
colorblind mode yeah yeah oh yeah cuz
you're colorblind right
yeah really tough for me so I have to
play yes or purple I mean it's not cool
that your color of mine but it's cool
that there's modes specifically like to
help with that I remember when we were
playing crystal crisis I was like we get
to play colorblind cuz you're colorblind
I'm sorry what have you ever tried those
glasses that like show you regular
colors I've heard of Gunners and I tried
looking for but those actually gave me a
headache
back didn't work out but I yeah I can't
any any eyewear just makes it worse is
Gunners there was like there's these
specific
like colorblind correction glasses that
I always watch videos of like people
gifting them to their friends they're
colorblind they try them on they start
crying and I'm like in tears watching
the video oh my god it's so beautiful
okay now I'm curious jeez yellow kill
says he's still rock good sir well I
think you guys enjoy my gameplay even
though I'm not getting everywhere I mean
still doing well getting some kills
let's drop superhot drop hot let's go to
language forest wherever that oh yeah
it's right at the start just a little
bit of a fighting chance alright we went
miles instead of space interesting where
could he be
it's okay they're a bad sniper yes you
like this place like there you go oh now
your opponent I think he just got smoked
Erik says he can't a bit because it's
just too hard with all the third party
and then he immediately followed up by
calling you a chicken for running
explosive
oh my god you got this you got this
explosive Phoenix ass how do you do
flips in the sky when you're coming down
that's part of the new emotes push on
PlayStation or they chant let's to see a
new champ who else you got somebody else
Yannick Phoenix you probably yeah get
that high ground well see yeah oh yeah
and then of course is like regular
ability is pretty good yeah I'll never
forget that clip you guys shared when
they were over in where was it like our
water Potter faith water treatment yeah
and these just Shh Oh Eric say he's
gonna stream snape you this solo battle
come on over to Xbox oh yeah
psych we're on Xbox Eric
everyone screams Sam yeah let's get a 60
person gamespot live stream stream one
versus 60 yeah that'll be really fun
that would be really not close good to
know you know what's that you talked
about water stream Emily yeah you know
that used to be the spot please together
all the time the new spot is like right
here just realize they're on Xbox he
said I'm coming for you and he's like Oh
what black so funny crimes like take
Rob's yeah I have an Xbox at my desk to
[Music]
the world you got this
well it's solos for a reason noise are
301 at the start it doesn't I think are
thrilling like one of my favorite guns
and then triple taken longbow or like my
favorites 900 action action Jackson
oh they're here
where is the question it's like even
more nerve-wracking when you're by
yourself there's every little sound it's
someone there oh hear him clean clinging
around over there minutes ago oh it's a
pathfinder too
oh he's picking up some Goods oh he's
out he's making a run for it where where
yeah where though no fear mags oh there
you okay
what does see him then I'm no fear it's
just I don't know where they are
originally I've devolved into something
worse I know right please started it
started with a dub and now we're just
regressed into a pleb Dan F says I think
clip size issues are gonna become real
apparent and singles uh yeah that's true
I agree I mean I already feel like most
of these guns like clip size is already
so short
yeah and when I get those like level
three like extended mags like yes I'm
unstoppable
I just pick up like a Spitfire something
was already a really large clip yeah
alright I'm gonna drop spicy I don't
like yeah yeah like that
so you mean we're actually we may be
dying a lot but at least you'll agree
same-origin
it's fine it's right off better than I'm
dining a lot with no action that's also
a thing yeah thanks for I guess that
means I have to move far okay we got
emotes
I can't wait to see what kind of plays
we see in like online from this area
with all the jump pads and so I'm sick
with that ring a fire won't that ring a
fire damaged but probably oh I saw
someone else's shadow land where you
both have a blow them be a good thing oh
that life's fine that's lifeline did no
damage suicide this is the ranch to the
spice so we need to cool it down a sec
so I'm gonna add a little bit of ranch
to that Bell star - no sorry those are
just laying around so loose huh yeah
maybe a try Bangalore or bloodhound I
saw someone recommending bloodhound in
chat earlier someone said yeah I've
definitely gone back downhill
it was first machen then I think it
ranked me and like oh you must be really
really good and I are just fighting for
a bunch of sweaty ZnO that's great
that was fun though you almost you
almost mean it out of there I mean I
feel like I'd like even made it out of
that situation also just a Mozambique
with no hair right wasn't beacon a dream
for reals
Mozambique with the two times I don't
know why I'm what I'm so bad at looting
guys I mean I can fight
with that lifeline crime no I'll know
he's trying to say say it is ooh
well no snipe age so I guess you've
successfully defended against the stream
snape we actually watched you die crime
so played Bob Bob okay Bob Kentucky sick
yes yes
but on circle this does the eSports pose
ease for noise
Oh My Lord gave you up and oh my god
blast to hear more feet yes you should
like unless those are your feet nothing
purple across the way there's something
in the middle of the Ring at the purple
helmet in the fire ring oh yes right
oh it's it's a shield I thought it was a
helmet cool Wow you're going for it I
already knew easy of course they had
nothing that we wanted but that purple
shield until the ring that is cool I
wonder if it's different every every
game Delfy somebody hear noise yeah
that's awesome
ah let's go max you got this that was
the that was that was all shot like I
don't care if I just know that was good
no good we got a couple bodies on the
list that was just one shot like inches
away and if you didn't have a purple
shield yeah yeah I wonder if you got
that one from the middle of the Ring
yeah that's so cool there's two jump
pads on the bottom already yeah there's
jump pads in that whole area already on
the floor okay I didn't see that all
right I'm gonna try to get that side
it's cool Alicia said please show us the
story we'll run through the store again
at the end of the stream leaves it a
little bit earlier but when I try to get
as many of these solo games in as we can
yeah we'll definitely check it out one
more time before we in the stream
because the skins are pretty dope
lifeline skin in my opinion is the best
one of the whole you know pack I'm just
gonna go cue cue at how I won't be able
to get that skin pay for creeps or hope
you get it in one of the crates I think
I could be wrong strat let me know but
that's as far as as far as I know it's
like overwatch style you either get in
the loo box or you buy more loot boxes
and hope to get it in loot box or you
already have the in-game currency you
need to like buy the skin so Chad I'm
just gonna keep yeah spicy keep going
for that Ring of Fire
ain't gonna but it'll be you know it'll
be fun see me fight some people instead
of just running around in the nova field
I'm not
are those both yours okay I thought they
only sent that one they could shoot out
too
what is in the ring no fire no use Blue
Shield's they definitely have a ton of
high-level shields in the back all day
how do you go to solo mode so there is a
little area right here and you click it
and you go everyw to solo see there's
also training regular mode ranked and
then solo ok well we'll run through the
shop again or the the stool oh cool I
wonder if these are just specific to the
event or are these just brand new oh
there's an iron crown specific music
okay
it's a little more more I think yeah
these like some gladiator fights war
instruments and stuff interesting
brand-new I'm sure the stream froze like
shroud and all of them are sweating over
this one wing man is how yeah yeah all
these awesome things to collect for the
iron crown oven that's kind of cool oh
it's like cute and I know I'd be the
same time he was like so proud of this
little skull so the blue token things I
think that's the iron crown currency
right yeah yeah always a separate
currency that's right mm-hmm
okay so like you can see and some of
them it specifically says like you have
to unlock this in open event packs to
unlock so it's you know these are
definitely all rng lets show the skins
one more time since we were already
there and I know some people in the chat
we're asking again so we got Bangalore
very clean one of Max's top 3 yeah it's
my second favorite so far
Rastafari Mirage Mirage looks like
someone I know actually in this whole
kit which is green I feel like I need to
screenshot that and send it to my friend
what's up
nice dummies sorry if I pronounced that
wrong yes the update is indeed out on
xbox we know that because we're playing
on xbox today yes now save the lifeline
skin for last because that is the best
[Music]
this one's pretty dull - yeah I like
that one a lot this is my number 2 the
shoulder pads are pretty big we'll see
bigboy and the nightfly and she's so
cool this looks like badass man she's
like a Jabberwocky mixed with Sombra
mixed with fans I'm at the Opera yeah
that mask is so cool
it's really awesome yeah definitely
talking you know cosplayers where you
add I need to see that oh and then the
axe also see which is probably heirloom
set but you can't you can't actually
select it and look at it like we did the
skins yeah
only that little thumbnail sorry crew so
can't read your joke because it's not
really a joke
if you send another good one like you
did earlier
then maybe then maybe
[Music]
all right back to wreath back to Google
with what the chat says and we'll just
keep rotating Eric Tay finally laid down
the hammer
I mean can't do what you gotta do
we're all having kids me plant some
solos are you so raised with the
champion of last game I'm gonna try to
identify the champion trends here on a
few dropping spring is not close it's
been very exhilarating when you got like
10 people in the same area I think a
major goal we need to set though is to
get whatever is in the middle of the
Ring of Fire at least once
yeah I feel like I should win at least
corner point like a lot like I think
that I was doing pretty well that I
should
steal game ran says how's the solo mo
what do you think max it's fun
you definitely need good headphones
because you definitely need to hear
people around you more a there's more of
enemies there's a bigger concentration
of enemy
right manager the regnum oh you just
listen
like a blue shield this time in the ring
well oh my goodness the ring around the
rosies oh my gosh she's so low there we
go that's what we needed
yeah I have heard the packs are pretty
expensive for this event
what is that puts a blue backpack got a
catch it on the way
noise score you successfully completed
the goal on the first first like game we
set it tribal box Oh hear the beats hey
little twinkle toes nice nice Oh looks
like nice that was literally like one
health and I refuse to believe other
heights one minute children gold barrel
I just so excited when you open up their
box do a good loot yeah go for those of
impacts you guys if you want to unlock
the skins because from what we saw in
the shop you know what's really tough I
can't really hear ya you know I think
it's something with this setup
specifically because there's something
first
yeah audio is super important guys if
you're I mean obviously you're not
playing with a team but like don't be in
like a party chat when you're in this
cuz you can't yeah you need to know
where they are
yeah footsteps it yes footsteps are
super crucial in this mode like if there
were those are two people coming up on
me yeah and I got sandwiched in between
both of them and I'm here either oh yeah
so that's not good is there a way to
unlock the packs without buying them
though I know you get packs when you
level up or when you complete challenges
right yeah alright your dailies and
stuff like that right you know what I
should be going for the dailies
yeah the dailies but there's actually
iron crown specific challenges I think
those ones get packed so I didn't
actually read them I should yeah let's
try to go for some of those maybe we'll
get lucky to get that lifeline skin next
time I die yes remind me crying said
he's having a lot of fun with octene in
the smoke as the auto heals we mentioned
that earlier and I think that's a huge
perk that ranks far yes a lot of objects
mm-hmm look every other person is often
it's my last
it's okay everyone can't see my dear
they all dropped bad
oh man let's get this party started
oh look all those shadows though so
money peacekeeper let's keep some peace
max let's go yes or the shields evade
evade there we go oh my he was camping
up on top of that bang I name was yeah
thing is on top of the little shovels
that's so grimy alright so get top 25
okay okay okay you talk to me 525 times
get 5 kills Octane's calm it I feel like
good oh that was okay so I got one
challenge that I beat before oh this is
a new one oh I bet you that first one
was you getting the thing out of the
Miller ring oh that's right yeah okay
okay so five kills that's why everyone's
going there you're close to 50 kills you
already like almost halfway alright okay
so now we've got some objectives I guess
we're going back to the gauntlet then
got to do it you got to do it for the
skins if we get a legendary skin on the
first pack I'm gonna lose my mind also
uh let me know if what character you
guys want to see next because I love
lifeline but I mean sorry Wraith can
play other characters yeah let's see
some oxy in action let's take him home
take him to his area
that's right
[Music]
yes I know he's so funny
you got to see that back sry video did
it come out recently where's that a
while ago it was like a day or two ago
oh yeah it was pretty recent champion or
I leave I was on Twitter ha
all right go until it
rings fire time for a joke I love his
voice acting so good actually pretty
much every voice acting up in this game
yeah I was gonna say they definitely you
know made all the characters different
and unique and gave them like culture
and individuality I like it I like is
Eva is running on the air
[Music]
you know I like using caustic because of
the caustic traps but he definitely
booked it no it's too much
that area is spicy oh yeah I was saying
I like caustics and using the traps I do
think they're like super good but you
have to go to like really enclosed
spaces like bunker or something for it
to have full effect I feel like I kind
of want to drops off this time work our
way let's work our way over and within
the gauntlet when like in school town
and then go over it I'm sure that's
spicy too but I feel like everyone stops
at gauntlet right now so you might be
able to like sneak over while there's
still some bodies to catch but you'll
have loot well actually it depends on
which way the ship is flying to know it
all Alaine next
the palm toward disorder is relentless
crime said F Mozambique yeah um as far
as the map there's the only new thing is
the gauntlet which is area we were in
basically kind of further boosting
Octane's backstory that we saw the text
chat logs between him and lifeline but
that's about it for the map specifically
is rather far and the next spring is
near gauntlet it's gonna be the drop
ships going to artillery I just want to
survive for kids
man I can't stop thinking about that
lifeline skin I know I'm just gonna like
cash in and get it oh man I really hate
spending real money like I really wanted
the new like me over watch skin that I
cosplayed and I tried so hard to get it
just through playing the game but my
orangey is just naturally horrible noise
ooh
okay she's got some good loot now that's
like here some action
yeah that sounds like it's all coming
from the gauntlet no rain crime says
like yeah I feel the way the same way
rng gods eat me aren't you gods they
look at me and they're like they just
laugh at me they they do not hear and
they love to watch me suffer we're
getting closer to the action be really
careful with my corners too a lot of
campers especially towards the end
I hear a lot of guns I don't see anybody
though yeah that's always the eerie part
what what other battle Royales have you
played did you play a lot of part night
or anything or club team play for night
for like it was definitely crazy because
it's not just like a shooter it's like a
shooter an a builder yeah yeah right I
just wasn't a fan I think a little bit
of pub G all my friends I don't know
something about like the movement and
like the fluidity and maybe I'm just too
good
I'm getting pinched here I know I'm like
where is everyone we're already like
halfway through
there's only 27 people 25 ooh
audio issues cuz when I opened those
boxes I couldn't hear them open behind
me yeah something I noticed that here
cuts out a little bit here and there
let's go get these daily challenges all
right here we go
you're prepared now I believe in you got
some shields oh yeah he's up there annie
has a cold shield of course I bet you
that one was in the Ring of Fire
yep the one time you didn't go there oh
of course I had a gold shield I'd be
running dude gold shield so good you hit
him so many times and he still had some
of the shield of that much damage
all right to this oh dang he hasn't
all-star dang we were hunting him for a
while - oh we got top five at least well
top 25 I mean yeah away away which
scroll up oh yeah
so we did not sing we did caustic who
else Marah
oh wait you didn't ROG game oh I think
yeah yeah oh yeah Mickey Peter listen
slow down he was actually a pretty good
in this cuz he was like yeah the
tracking was good yeah I think the time
that you did use it it was like against
another bloodhound
[Music]
today four to five minutes
I know if the sort is okay and it has
been downhill after we still have more
than 20 minutes to get another ee you
got this nice I'm trying
we got that we've got the first one on
the street even though there's only how
we do it still yeah if I go just as ham
now I just die so you're overthinking it
just gotta go with the flow see the
first game we're like this is just a
test
alright this is just a test max okay
this is also all just a test
when did the map change says anonymous
ash about two hours ago yeah
looks like it was safe area we just need
some good loot this is not good loot a
whole room for one shield cell oh man
you've got to even wingman so b67 damage
might yes yes you did blood now I'm
really trying to listen Alex I'm really
doing good gangbang
men make these decisions fast mags he
went like he has to be hiding under you
yep everyone is indeed solo anonymous
solo mode honestly I know this is a
limited like runs mode but there are a
lot of people who will go into regular
mode and just drop solo anyway which
totally you know ruins it for the other
people so you know I wouldn't mind if it
wasn't just the limited mode so that
those people can have a mote of their
own and they don't have to like kill it
for the whole team you know yeah not
sure as hell hey is that
now I'm curious like what's in that ring
every time oh no it's okay that might
have been for the best it's time to go I
really can't hear any of those gunshots
yeah we might have been distracted yeah
I mean I'm totally downstairs go through
betas or tests and stuff like that
because you know at the end of the day
they're just trying to make the best
game possible for us so I just hope
after they work out all the key steps
they keep it around I think there's
definitely a place for this mode in this
game
ooh another gold barrel stabilizer I
know I like your someone's watching you
do that somebody actually there's like a
little eyeball next to your kill
accounts oh that means someone
spectating you right oh yeah they
probably just went afk
yes max is colorblind recycling in
colorblind mode I think it's cool I
don't know why but I always geek out
whenever I play games with Max and he
uses colorblind mode yeah red resin
Brown you're not completely colorblind
but just reds and browns earth and
that's like all of this whole map yeah
all the sand and everything alright
sixteen players left
Oh yep someone's in here sure the steps
sounded too quick to be yours but it
could have also been here how do you
feel about the supply ships you think
they're a deathtrap
yeah I'm not a fan unless I like
absolutely have to go there my whole
team's there then I'll go but like I
don't just like to roll in by myself cuz
usually it's a recipe for disaster
how'd you pull this area off yeah just
in case there's any stragglers
that's always the worst you're like
running towards the ring and you see
someone on the inside of the wall how do
you even fight that yeah I kind of like
Crouch walk like every few seconds oh no
it's cage
do you like the creeper I do it's just
very hard to hit though yeah it's I mean
it's like the most satisfying gun in the
game when you what that's like
oh snap we're almost in the top ten
[Music]
let's go definitely hit some action Oh
yep Oh time to interfere with this
battle you don't see you he's not being
attention
Oh crud oh my
there we go I'm actually wrong
yeah we need to reload all to me real
quick being alternator was the purpose
in a night and he got that gold barrel
and the disrupting realms I think we're
we're slated for a W here Eric's
cheering you on let's go max sniffing
out oh my god
that was a rough one I missed all those
shots Oh be swift and diligent
god those are the Spitfire shocks are
not raining I mean it was raised too but
I don't like that yeah that that Wraith
up there I thought I would hear him walk
up to the box that just yeah but you're
like um your ability and that was clutch
yeah cuz he could see all the little
markings yeah I definitely could tell
that he came by recently cuz at first I
thought it was from the guy you killed
but it only lasts like a minute or
something last minute but it was it was
like a it was like a fifty second one
and then there's like a twenty second
was like oh and somebody's been here oh
yeah oh okay and see him over there we
got a little bit of a fight happening
but the Rings clothing which is only
good news for you right now okay we're
we are stocked up your alternator is
beauty straight now this is what we live
for
oh four players left only three more
bodies to catch I'm not going top oh
thank you oh wait no it's not
it's okay it's okay they don't see you
no care packages landed next to you -
yeah actually I'm pretty good on good
right now yeah to what extent if I don't
have to only three more people Eric so
stay confident he's sending youbut a way
through Chad I know there's nobody
behind me okay so someone sees you that
much we do know I don't know where you
guys are at oh wait did he just quit he
quit but he's definitely outside of the
ring now so this guy went up to the top
but that area is about to be yeah so
just have the way to mount a little bit
oh okay
okay yeah he's on the second floor gold
shield
oh man oh man
it's okay cuz you know you're in a
really good position the next ring is
very close to you Lily oh my
hmm those were good shots it's okay let
him stay up there yes sir comes you they
all have to come to you let me take high
ground actually just keep an eye on the
ring you're gonna really good spot yeah
unless somebody comes through this rock
area we first sure have seen the two
other people here
oh yeah they're fighting right now you
got this max buddy's dude that knockdown
now it gives us self revive the last
person
let's go let's go
all right so I got to W on this name
it's like oh this is good this is good
very good finish with the execution on
top of that champion execution we had
the beast most beast alternator that
pretty much saved money she had a gold
shield nice that thing was like gone wow
that's cool
very nice so yeah bloodhound definitely
looking like a great fantastic choice
for solos he is a contender for sure oh
and you are officially halfway to
getting your kid skills for your daily
challenge oh nice 25 kills in the stream
not bad not bad the chat is curious as
to what your settings are you put a
default or anything crazy
you know I just pull it up I don't even
remember I had it on for sensitivities
for a while but I noticed that my shots
are just not eating
so just like yeah basically just like
you can't really flick on console but
yeah just a flick ability for it just
accuracy because I just wasn't landing
my shots so wanted to go with the low
sensitivity instead and that's working
out Oh Eric said his alone ones with
blood bloodhound also oh really
starting to see a trend yeah nothing
fazes me and you're at the champion this
ring is not close good - oh you know
what I'll show you my settings after I
land the pro strats actually yeah
probably focus
it almost looked like it
they're going to hydro damn
yes yes everyone sending their Gigi's to
you in the chat providing these quality
wins and I have my recording device
active so we also got that on camera the
proof a gun would be nice yep I heard
him sound like a pathfinder tell you max
the trip will take you know he didn't
want that by choice big ooh that's what
we call a big that's all he's like two
feet away from you maybe they need them
you know the sound radius a little
shorter in solos or I'll shoot just be
hearing footsteps in like every
direction
freaking out so paranoid that's right
Eric toxicity doesn't belong here we are
positive people and that is how we roll
little bit oh yeah five minutes ago
oh snap run back the Beast alternator
please oh yeah I can you just need to
find all the pieces to the puzzle okay
Exodia yeah I mean like good the game is
like you can't pick anything else up
like a JanSport columbia or we go to
Northeast I know
give me that Ari I stood
oh my god please all right this really
sucks
yeah drop some of those throwables you
already have two of those you know I
need another one you know actually I
think there we go the designer bags yeah
the gold one is the Gucci Gucci bag for
sure where's his ring at I know I didn't
really loot that very well but it's all
good just kind of go somewhere with
better stuff I'm not liking this
actually I'm gonna write to people on
the way for sure Apollo says got my
first seven kill win with Gibby before
work ing is real and solos yeah you have
to land on something good and it's like
you want people to be around but I don't
want too many whoa that was weird
someone and if you look to your left
this is the championship area that max
just one is last game on through as
people say doesn't feel like more safe
playing as wraiths be just because of
the passives I knew whatever look at me
mines it's like having like insurance or
something well you got against the
ground Maggs it helps with that landing
leg
this is very quietly I know it's too
quiet father no we don't even hear any
crossfire no 24 people still alive I
really don't like this there's gonna be
somebody up here
yeah Paulo we did check out the gauntlet
and we actually got a blue backpack from
the Ring of Fire
but we saw that you know every round
there with some new stuff like a purple
shields the blue backpack I don't
remember what else I saw anything else I
think those are only two times we
actually noticed there was something
there it definitely changes around cool
them because I was wondering like you
know what else is like important about
this area or different or unique and I
was one of them so kudos I think one tip
on the jump area is uh just take the
jump pad normally I know there's the
jump pad trick to like jump extra if you
time it right but then you go flying
over don't bring a fire yeah
Oh someone just took a balloon over
there
face your fears max what's it anime song
I do not know we're gonna need you to
sing it very accurately for us no we've
come and save me I don't know which one
I hate any scope that isn't like a one
time let's go the two time scope is
actually pretty nice in my opinion
oh man I really don't like this all
right I'm gonna go towards the fire
fight guys I'm probably gonna die but no
you got this you're superior with the
aim like Eric said earlier stay
confidence you're the champion actually
you know feel good about that we're
getting closer I can't tell which
direction that's coming tonight my audio
issues are your headphones on backwards
I hope you know I you know what I'm
gonna check that for justice no you're
good I just saw it yeah oh what's on top
of the building oh wait sorry that was a
dragon
guys he like flew across the top of the
building and I thought it was like a
prison so a trick on console guys is
he's not auto-aim tech yeah using an
auto aim tech since it starts slowing
down then it means that there's somebody
in your slide so like somewhere in this
area there's somebody here yeah though
it's cold school tick but like whenever
that you salmon in Halo is always like
on accident and I'd be like no it
accidentally locked onto somebody out
for a while I had to turn that off
because of stuff like that like trying
to snipe and someone runs by and it
pulls the gun or like the worst is like
when you're fighting two people oh yeah
like the auto aim freaks out and like
tries to target between them and that's
always good I mean sighs annex ring all
right I've got some high ground there's
definitely somebody here I just can't
see you know
there's so many places they could be no
I don't like it
10 players left in the stream with
another dubbing almost now it's all good
you're a brave look at the map well
completely yeah I would like if here's
where you got sniped
so yeah default 3 all around you crazy I
don't think there's auto aim on
teammates one minute and children cries
well at least there wasn't in halo cuz I
remember you know in each old there is a
battle that's all three people in front
of you there's one week right here at
below you or on top the hill and one
across the hill oh gosh he's right
ah crap man now it's getting wild
we didn't revive his shields yeah run
max run and heal it's oh boy holy smokes
snack then you're running low on some
healing supplies your head I think it's
the game focus like very suit like the
mine stuff it's really loud but there
gunshot oh yeah I have noticed the audio
is a bit different even on my in
a better shield would be really nice
right now 30 seconds until close all
right
we're still alive though five more
enemies then I need to like a third
party or whatever the heck is gonna
happen cuz I can't fight like this
yeah find some loot boxes around every
little branch and pebble on the way
alright
ring is now closing some death boxes
over there I saw blue one means you get
a blue shield with some close supply
crates but I wonder why alright
someone's looking oh my goodness I'm
sorry that's scared the bejesus out of
me that grenade was super quiet it'll
explode yeah yeah the base was like plus
20
actually it is oh you know what okay
well let this be the last game oh we
have reached our time through this dream
but you know what we can't go out like
that no I got lucky I was born with the
grenade just go super spicy and we'll
see what happens
okay you could totally just drop like 15
kills right now with one Mozambique and
a white shield
hey I'm since I've seen crazier things
happen
I mean with a hammer point and nobody I
don't think man that grenades scared the
crap out of me I was so focused you
[Music]
start to loot just takes too long and I
just start getting blocked no but you're
right though you're a passive should I
went off if they're looking at you and
they're throwing your grenade I use so I
don't know how much you know more
looking at you needs to be doing spicy
guys Otto Otto picked again the one more
game syndrome yeah I'll go back to the
the new area for a bit yeah I notice
that there was actually like roof over
their Stadium mmm-hmm when your flute
job something I'm pretty sure it's like
the no access so and I'll sort it oh
right
get back to the battlefield
we are currently playing on Xbox one
all right back to the gauntlet only saw
one other shadow Oh a gold helmet it's
lagging oh no no let's go say maybe you
jerked him I think he did yeah there's a
lot of people just go to your left and
come back there oh no no grounds I hate
the Scout make one of my top ten least
favorite guns hey yep
dude just open the door if something's
already heard where'd you go I
definitely always here somewhere don't
you wish you had that bloodhound it's
too eerie we just saw like 50 people
over here ooh nice
yeah that cradle yeah I can barely hear
it every single tiny overnight or maybe
just something new they're trying in
terms of like listening some of the
audio cassette is definitely one
extremely huge aspect of this game the
second I hear footsteps I stopped
walking at Crouch put my back to a
corner and then figure out where they're
running and then try to go from there
every time yep Robo turtle this is the
new solo limited edition mode it just
dropped today with the iron crown
collection event alongside a bunch of
skins really awesome skins by the way
really good a couple other cool things
so be sure to check it out
and of course now that I want to die I
can't find up there none of the skins
are like free free free like you can buy
them with in-game currency you can score
them in a loop box but not free you
can't just like sign in and use it
although they look pretty cool
[Applause]
yeah I would say the solos is definitely
slower for some reason like in my mind
it's harder to find people yeah I
figured it would be more chaotic because
everyone against each other but from
what I've noticed so far in these games
there is a lot of downtime like he'll be
real spicy when he'll and depending on
where you land and then you might not
see anybody ever oh my gosh oh man he
says she got the cojones to go through
this portal and chasey oh I don't know
that's actually like one of the first
lifelines I've seen in solos
to a little bit there's her bot where
are you where he's crouched walking
somewhere come on
see this is why audio so crazy both of
you guys are crouching right now and
waiting for each other I can't like I
can hear those gunshots that distance
but like opening a great right next to
you it sounds like it's 10 miles away
all right I guess who's gonna give him
free
she gave him first barely though you
only go where is she I'm definitely here
yeah
it's a fear already she's searching
she's on the hunt Oh someone else
oh my gosh
so max go max it was a raid so yeah they
took often stayed gone or came back oh
he's here
hello
yeah oh well now you know which
direction is she's sharing something
[Music]
that's cool it's fine
got some doves cause um it was a good
day yes a good time good time we had a
good time we hope you guys had a good
time go download the updates and trying
to get the use of skins specifically
that lifeline is good it is nice thank
you guys so much for tuning in tomorrow
unfortunately we will not have a stream
tomorrow because here in the office we
were doing some very important meetings
and trainings to make sure that we're
all having a great old time here it
works so no shooting tomorrow but we'll
be back Thursday and of course community
Friday is this Friday with some kt11
action that night wolf hot off the
presses
like yesterday yeah today so for those
of you into MK 11 make sure you come
back on Friday so you couldn't play with
Ben and John Luke but until then
everyone have a great day and we will
see you guys next time
[Music]
you